Oh notes vasa Nega looks great in a
dress
honored wanted to become governor of
Alaska but are not new
oh no he could never become such a thing
he wanted to become the first faithful
woman this town has ever known and
whatever it takes to get there I would
do
so he set out on his journey
car to MIT and the ball got it I thank
you
I know they accepted the quests of
baseball he was filled with excitement
he could really run in those high heels
couldn't he
oh no need knew he needed to find the
outfit typical God what the [ __ ] is that
okay.what [ __ ] you you're ugly
who allowed something so ugly to live
[ __ ] you I'm not going near that [ __ ]
catch everything on the list
there we go good ol Arnall ready to kick
some ass oh yeah I downloaded a mod that
makes me so I can beat the [ __ ] out of
kids let's see if it works okay okay
that it did work oh my god I love the
baseball's so good oh [ __ ] that's
choosing my site let's find more kids
don't beat the [ __ ] out of them that's
what baseball is all about you're not a
kid there you go we got her together
nice one this is how your baseball mate
[ __ ] are all the kids okay actually
there's one more thing I want to try it
really quick okay there's this weapon
called the junk yet which basically lets
you put whatever you want inside it and
shoot it out look at this [ __ ] ok
let's what should we put a teddy bear
all right let's find the kid again and
shoot a teddy bear in his face [ __ ]
face you can you can you you can you
shoot teddy bears and kids faces and
people still ask what's better console
or PC like I don't understand why is
that even a [ __ ] question hey Ken
baseball yeah let's charge it with
baseballs where's that [ __ ] kid go
the [ __ ] you go hey ass [ __ ] come
back here that's right [ __ ] yeah you
better run let's charge a screwdriver
come back here unknown ones to play come
back here you piece of [ __ ] you think
you can hide that's right [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
yeah I feel like the [ __ ] predator
alien
ah fish went down yes you're right me
look at me look at me what does it know
stay down
there we go just lay still buddy just
lay still there you go oh Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] there's someone in the
fridge indiana jones 2sat you oh god
you're ugly
oh god it's a kid
Allen wanted to be a baseball player but
that was not enough he wanted to be a
woman baseball player yes very nice he
also wanted to be naked
oh yes look at that naked for reals I
wonder if this will break the game
Arnaud knew that he needed to cleanse
his lands from the entia well [ __ ] you
looking at me
Esther I pitched La Paz and it's at that
moment I'll not know that he was finally